Sup, friends.
This here is a short video on the use of stylets and bougies for pediatric intubations.
Quick disclaimer, this isn't our main jam and our experience is limited in this area,
but we do think there are some important things to discuss and hope it's of value.
If there are any specialists in this area that want to collaborate on some other stuff
in the future, definitely reach out.
Alright, let's dig in on this.
Bougies are all the craze these days and we imagine many people are using them in the
field routinely, which is awesome.
Bougies have been around for a hot minute as a backup tool for difficult airways, but
they're gaining popularity in both the hospital and pre-hospital scenes.
Most resources on airway management and EMS these days at least discuss their use in the
adult population.
Initial data on the routine use of bougies was limited to certain settings and researchers
noted that findings about increased first-pass success could not be generalized across the
board and that's fair, especially when it comes to EMS and out-of-hospital medicine.
Things don't always translate.
Subsequent studies, however, have gone on to demonstrate the efficacy of bougies in
the out-of-hospital setting in increasing first-pass success.
So now there's no excuse not to use a bougie on the adult patient.
The data is there, most of us have access to them, and there's all kinds of techniques.
That said, be aware that there is some confounding data.
As with all things in medicine, it can be tough to know what actual best practice is.
The BEAM study in 2018 essentially said bougie's best in the ER setting.
This 2021 study focused on patient populations in both the MICU and ER and headed by the
same lead researcher failed to arrive at a similar conclusion.
But anyways, the general consensus is that bougie use is fairly well supported for EMS
folks and in the adult population, but it isn't as simple as grabbing the thing and
using it within an airway management framework that we were all taught in medical school.
Bouges require specific knowledge and techniques to be effective.
We put some short videos up a while back showing three different ways in which the bougie could
be used by a single provider.
We collectively labeled them one human bougie techniques.
If our take on it isn't enough, Foamfratt recently did a podcast blog combo explaining
a few more of the techniques that are out there and included a thorough overview of
current research and a discussion of application in the field.
There's also the OG approach using two providers, with one of them feeding the E2 tube over
the bougie while the other performs laryngoscopy.
And that's almost always possible to do in the pre-hospital setting.
It's quite rare that we don't have extra hands on scene.
This video is from the Protected Airway channel on Instagram.
So we have all the school stuff, but does it translate to pediatric patients?
What works for adults may not work for kids.
And what about neonates and infants specifically?
We'll try and answer those questions over the next few minutes and then we'll eventually
follow up with a neonatal specific video at a later date.
First thing to note is that the bougie may not fit in smaller sized ET tubes.
The 10 French pediatric bougie will fit snugly inside a 402 but won't work for smaller sizes.
If all that is available are the 15 French adult ones, those go down to a 5.5 tube.
Set a different way, the adult 15 French bougie will work down to a 5.5 tube or for kids of
about 6 years old.
The pediatric 10 French bougie will work down to a 402 or for an infant of about 4 months.
And these ages are approximate.
Use a braso tape on scene to size things out right.
Now the argument could be made to just use a pediatric 10 French bougie for all the tube
sizes as both the 15 French and 10 French often come in the same length.
The issue with that however is that the 10 French pediatric bougie is a bit less rigid.
This makes the thing more difficult to control and also throws a wrench in the utilization
of some of our preloaded techniques.
The weight of an adult tube may be too much for the pediatric bougie to support.
More on that later.
Now they do make smaller bougies for neonates that can fit inside 2.0 or 2.5 tubes but those
are tough to come by and not all that common.
We hope to get our hands on one soon and we'll post a subsequent video when that happens.
There's also the thought that most of us won't be intubating neonates or infants and a 402
which is compatible with the standard 10 French pediatric bougie will work for nearly
all of our patients.
And then there are also some concerns and issues about all that which we'll get to
soon so let's move on.
Another thing to note when using a smaller bougie is that some of the preloaded techniques
don't work.
For example the Murphy's eye at the end of the tube may not accommodate the bougie.
The size of the eye varies a tad by manufacturer so just know how the stuff in a given kit
fits.
And as mentioned before we may also find that the system ends up being a bit top heavy when
compared to the adult technique.
This is because the adult bougie is a bit more robust and can support the weight of
the E2 tube.
That may not be the case with a smaller bougie.
Not an absolute game changer but just something to be aware of.
This is also one of the reasons why we don't use the pediatric 10 French size for all patients
just with tubes that don't fit on the adult one.
And that's totally fine.
There are other ways to make the thing happen.
Use a friend to load the tube on the bougie.
Figure out a way to do it alone without preloading the thing or just get used to the differences
with whatever technique gets used.
Let's summarize up to this point.
Bougies have demonstrable value in increasing first pass success in grownups.
There's lots of ways to look cool using the bougie so everyone should be able to find
a way that works for him or her.
Some techniques aren't awesome with or may need to be modified for pediatrics.
But what does the data have to say about all of this?
First thing to consider is that the younger a patient is, i.e. as age approaches zero,
the more of a difference there is from adult anatomy.
We've all seen graphics similar to this one that notate the differences between adult
and pediatric airways.
The point to make is that these differences are most apparent at the neonate or infant
end of the spectrum and less marked for pediatrics as age goes up.
So let's take a moment and focus on the left end of the spectrum and talk about neonatal
and infant airway management.
We'll come back to this middle area of children in just a little bit.
Now this may be news to some but not all neonatal and infant airway people use stilets.
There is some concern that the rigid stilets can cause damage to the airway.
There is also concern that the plastic at the distal tip of the stilets can shear off
into the airway.
Because of this, most guidelines for neonatal or infant airway management mention the stilets
as an optional piece of equipment.
There was a 2017 Cochrane review in the infant population and then a 2021 study on the neonatal
population, both of which compared the use of a stilets with a no-stilets approach and
neither study could confirm that stilets use yields better outcomes.
The takeaway here is that stilets use with the neonatal or infant is at the provider's
discretion, unless for those of us in the EMS field we have more specific instruction
provided to us by medical direction.
That said, there are some potential advantages to using a stilets and therefore a bougie
as well for these patient populations.
One idea is that the stilets allow the clinician to shape a bend in the end of the tube.
A shallow angle is often preferred with younger patients, while a more defined hockey stick
shape is often the norm for adult patients.
Given that nearly all ET tubes come packaged with a notable bend in them, using a tool
to reshape them into a shallower angle, i.e. a stilet, or using a tool that presents with
a shallower angle, i.e. a bougie, may make more sense.
And what about the bougie specifically?
There was a 2015 simulation study that showed promise of bougie use in shortening the time
to a definitive airway, as well as success in some difficult airway scenarios.
And note that this was specific to infants and done in simulation on mannequins.
That said, progress has been slow and confounded by case studies of complications related to
bougie use.
For example, pneumothoraces caused by bougies, as shown in this chest X-ray, can be quite
discouraging.
It is worth noting, however, that neonatal bougies are sometimes straight in design and
without the coup d'etat tip we typically see.
That coup d'etat tip provides protection against the distal end of the device going beyond
the carina and into the bronchi.
This mechanism is known and well-established for adults and presumed for infants.
If anyone has for sure data on that, just let us know.
In the meantime, consider using coup d'etat bougies when possible.
One more point on this prior set of images.
We have not seen a coup d'etat tip neo-bougie that fits in a 2.02.
The one pictured here on the bottom fits down to a 2.5.
And that one on the top that does fit a 2.0 has the straight tip that isn't ideal.
We imagine they're out there, they're just not that common.
If you have one, let us know.
We'd love to get our hands on one and make some more videos.
Alright, let's summarize the neonate infant discussion up to this point.
Some folks don't use stylets at all due to concern with sticking a rigid metal rod down
the baby's throat.
There's also the possibility of shearing the plastic off the distal end of the stylet
and into the airways, especially when that end extends past the ET tube.
That said, stylets do allow the clinician to dictate the shape of the tool and may facilitate
the correct placement.
As for bougies, data is scant at this point, but the use of a coup d'etat bougie likely
eliminates the number one concern of causing a pneumothorax.
Takeaway here is that there's no right or wrong, just a handful of options, each with
positives and negatives.
And then what about the middle ground we mentioned earlier?
The data is clearer for adults, not so clear for neonates and infants, but what about pediatric
patients in between those two extremes?
Again, the data here is pretty inconclusive.
Let's start with stylets.
We already mentioned that the ability to shape the ET tube using a rigid stylet may facilitate
tube placement in general.
More specifically, Lee and friends in a recent study demonstrated the value of using a specific
technique when performing laryngoscopy with a hyperangulated blade.
They used a much deeper angle that matches the shape of the blade and then bent the distal
tip to the left just a smidge.
These modifications resulted in improved success in patients aged 1 to 5 years old.
So that's cool, and there may be advantages to the stylet, whether with a standard blade
or with a hyperangulated blade, but know that the data isn't solid and for now it's at
each clinician's discretion.
As for bougies, there is some consensus that they do have a place in difficult pediatric
airways, but adoption for routine use is still up in the air.
For those on the fence about bougie use for children, here's a few things to consider
when trying to proactively plan an airway strategy for pediatric patients that aren't
on that extremely low end age of the spectrum where anatomical difference are most extreme.
The technique doesn't have to be all that different from whatever technique is used
for adult patients.
And in the case that a preferred technique isn't compatible with all size ranges, using
the equipment on hand at a given service, there are valid alternatives available.
Having a bougie on hand also offers some flexibility if things get weird.
Consider for example the need to place a backup airway.
It can be exchanged for an ET tube via a blind insertion technique.
There's not much in the literature about this technique with pediatrics, but we imagine it's
only a matter of time until it catches on.
It's also good to have the bougie immediately available if a crec needs to be performed,
or a chest tube.
All that said, here's where we stand on the issue at this point in time.
If bougies are available, use them during the initial intubation attempt.
If pediatric ones are available, use them.
If the itty bitty ones are there too, use them also.
But a couple of caveats here.
Follow these steps for best practice.
Practice using the thing in all its different size iterations so that time isn't lost when
push comes to shove.
Some trials have shown that bougie use adds time to establishing a definitive airway,
and this is likely due to a deficit in familiarity and training with the device.
Specifically, know how to manipulate the distal tip of the bougie while using various techniques.
Also consider adjusting the intubation technique so that the blade, whichever kind is being
used, stays in the mouth until the ET tube is passed.
Railroading the tube blindly can lead to injury, especially if the bougie fits snugly inside
of the ET tube.
Check out this article at the AirwayJetta website for complete discussion of this idea.
Next idea.
Know that there may still be a place for rigid stilets.
One example is when using a hyper-angulated video laryngoscope.
It may be tough to maneuver a bougie, or even an ET tube without a stilet at all, between
the cords due to the geometry of the device and the approach afforded by the blade.
If using a hyper-angulated blade, consider using a stilet and get familiar with shaping
it just right to facilitate tube placement.
Another thought here is that the bougie or stilet, or lack thereof, none of these things
help with visualization.
Remember to incorporate other techniques to facilitate that part of it all.
Examples would be external laryngil manipulation or lifting the head during laryngoscopy.
For more on this idea, check out that MCRIT video.
And then last bit of advice.
Don't get roped into any one technique or preference.
Recognize that practice changes and stay up to date on things.
We do think that the bougie should be in hand on the first attempt when possible, regardless
of age, and imagine that data to support this idea will continue to grow in the coming years,
especially as it relates to pediatric airway management.
The biggest holdup to successful use of the bougie at this point is clinician familiarity
with the tool.
We'll do our best to keep everyone updated as new things come out, and in the meantime,
definitely let us know if there's stuff that we need to know.